last night leftist students at George
Washington University shrieked and they
screamed and they stormed out during my
speech because I defended George
Washington at George Washington
University meanwhile students at the
Catholic Notre Dame University performed
slam poetry and accused their classmates
of murder because wait for it
those classmates espoused Catholic
social views conservatives knee-jerk
reaction to these kids is to blame them
as wacky and snowflakes and all of
that's obviously true but we will
examine whether or not there is some
deeper reason why the kids obviously are
not all right then a profoundly moving
moment at amber Geiger's murder trial
Maxine Waters as chickens come home to
roost and finally the mailbag I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
so I'm at George Washington University
last night in DC and this is the third
stop on this year's campus tour on the
men are not women and other
uncomfortable truths tour and the reason
the tour is called men are not women and
other uncomfortable truths is because
last spring when I was at the University
of Missouri Kansas City I gave what I
figured was my blandest speech ever
which was called men or not women if
you've gone back three years and told
somebody that this would be a
controversial speech they would laugh in
your face but at that speech the student
shrieked and they screamed and they
stormed out and one guy attacked me with
a super soaker full of we don't know
what kind of creepy chemicals so I
thought that was it that was the peak of
basic facts about life that could make
left-wingers irate until I went to
George Washington University because I
was invited to George Washington
University to give a speech defending
George Washington and specifically their
mascot which is George the colonial who
is George Washington figure this should
be pretty easy not only am i defending
one of the greatest men to ever live in
the father of our country first and war
first in peace and first of the heart in
the hearts of his countrymen I'm doing
it at George Washington University and I
know the universities are crazy now but
you figure if you choose to go to a
university called George Washington
University probably you at least don't
hate George Washington I was so wrong
how wrong I was I'm giving the speech
about ten minutes in some alarm goes off
and as I'm just describing some of
George Washington's historical feats
some pretty basic aspect of Washington's
life these students leap to their feet
and start shrieking profanities
vulgarities fu fu you're a fascist and I
asked understanding they're asking them
what did I say that you object to what
did I say that is making you call me all
these things and making you have this
hysterical emotional breakdown in a
classroom none of them could give any
sort of answer here's just a short taste
of the students leaping to their feet
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
see it's hard to hear over this shrieks
and the shame and fascist and all this
but what I what I mentioned is that a
lot of the reason why left wingers at
colleges get upset by George Washington
where they get upset by Christopher
Columbus where they get upset by America
itself is because of ignorance because
they're uneducated and obviously
students are uneducated they're getting
educated that's why they're students but
they're particularly uneducated these
days because they have not been taught
the history of their own country and in
many ways they've been taught an anti
history of their country written by
left-wing polemicists like Howard Zinn
for instance who wrote people's history
the United States so I made this point
and then right on cue these kids jump up
and start shrinking nonsense and I said
you know you're really you're really not
disproving my point here kids if you
want to if the point you're trying to
make is that you're really not
uneducated you're really not emotionally
volatile and and wacky then probably
this is not the sort of behavior you
should engage in so the kids finally
storm out and we go on with the rest of
the lecture this has happened to me a
few times on campuses ironically it
always happens when I'm discussing the
blandest topics but I notice in this
culture it's the most basic truths that
are the truths that the left wants to
deny they have to force you to not
believe your own lyin eyes so they have
to force you not to believe that men are
different than women they have to force
you to believe the men are the same as
women and if you challenge this then
they'll shriek at you
have to force you to believe that your
country America is just absolutely
rotten to the core and nobody's more
rotten than the founder of the country
and if you say no that that really isn't
backed up by any historical evidence
they'll shriek and they'll scream and
they'll shout it's very easy to just
laugh at the snowflakes and drink their
leftist tears I do that I enjoy doing
that but also we need to ask ourselves
why is this happening what does it say
about the culture and how can we fix it
because it's not just happening at GW
another another viral video came out of
Notre Dame I went to Notre Dame I was
actually defending another historical
figure there Christopher Columbus and
some students protested all of that but
just this week we had a bunch of
students put out this video and it went
viral on the Internet where the students
were lambasted their their classmates
for holding catholic views so this was a
group of leftist students who were
accusing their classmates of being
homophobic and transphobic and murderers
even because they believed in christian
sexual ethics because they believed in
the teachings of the Catholic Church I
know that I don't need to remind you
Notre Dame means Our Lady Notre Dame is
a Catholic University or at least it
used to be it's nominally a Catholic
University it's really the most famous
Catholic University in the United States
and these students who chose to go to
Notre Dame who are Notre Dame students
they they went there it's like the
students who choose to go to George
Washington University even though they
hate George Washington these are
students who chose to go to a Catholic
University are shocked and appalled that
some of their classmates are Catholics
and they're they're shocked and appalled
and they want to shut them down and they
want these students not to be allowed to
have their clubs and not to be allowed
to publish their thoughts and to espouse
Catholic social views so they chose that
they decided the best way that they
could get their message out was through
performance art and slam poetry and slam
poetry is the death of art slam poetry
is I know it's not considered a crime in
the US legal code though of course it
should be and I intend to lobby my
Congressman to make it a crime it is
such an offense
and art it is such an offense against
beauty but this is the way they do it
because the left loves this form of art
and they love all forms of art that are
that are destructive and ugly
so here is just a little taste of of
these kids these leftist students at
notre-dame lambasted baselessly smearing
their classmates of murder because they
can't understand like students at a
Catholic University might be Catholic
you're homophobic discourse soiled my
air supply your ivory tower theology
slip my loved ones throats I'm trying to
go to class without dead friends in my
backpack just trying to touch my girl's
shoulder in the grass you want to uh
nifer me to lobotomize me with a crowbar
well the murdered trans angels 18 this
year yet leak brimstone into your
praying mouths students for child
oriented policy Irish Rover you say my
piece had violent undertones that it
drew hostile attention you say
expressing a Catholic viewpoint should
not be equated to committing a heinous
crime you contrasted your reasoned
opinion with my intellectual chaos that
you are targeted but I must respectfully
say that the blood on your name's did
not come from you or the hate groups
you've been inviting to speak on campus
it was ours and my loved ones your
reasoned opinions seep into churches
into culture they diffuse like venomous
gas from every outlet that is the very
nature of discourse so it goes on I'll
spare you the rest at one point a girl
takes a crowbar to a list of the
students names and starts banging and
obviously obviously these kids are
ignorant and uncultured and prideful and
they produce terrible terrible terrible
art obviously that is true okay but it's
not entirely their fault and what
they're saying is very very interesting
and important what that girl just said
is that reasoned arguments are venomous
that reason itself logic the
interpretation of facts to produce a
coherent argument is venomous poison
destructive it's got to be gotten rid of
this is not their fault entirely it's
partially their fault but it reminds me
of the difference the main difference
between a conservative and a radical and
it shows maybe how conservatives should
react to these guys first before we get
to that I've got to thank our friends
over at brick house have you ever
wondered why Americans are so sick
unhealthy and overweight these days
obviously they've they've got some
intellectual problems going on but
they've got a lot of physical problems
too Americans are very sedentary they're
unhealthy they're overweight they're not
skinny boys there aren't that many
skinny boys left in the country between
the food supply and the sedentary
lifestyle Americans are in worse shape
than ever that is why the team of on
staff physicians at brickHouse nutrition
created field of greens I love field of
greens field of greens makes my life
much simpler makes it easier and it will
do the same for you it's an easy way for
you to add fruits and vegetables to your
daily routine without spending hours in
the produce section or hiring a home
chef for taking those cheap supplements
I love field of greens because for me if
I were left on my own I've been on the
road for the past week my diet would
consist of fatty Italian meats and maybe
homemade pasta that's that would be it
I guess maybe some cheese but mostly
fatty Italian meats is what I'm saying
and that's not good for you all the time
field of greens is made with real USDA
organic fruits and vegetables it helps
boost your immunity using antioxidants
and assists digestive health with
prebiotics and probiotics it is like
having a doctor and a nutritionist in
your kitchen one scoop of field of
greens delivers a full serving of fruits
and vegetables you just drop it in a cup
of water stir it you're done it's also
very good for smoothies bottom line here
this is real food okay this is not
extracts this is not some weird bizarre
chemical experiment this is real food
you will look better you will feel
better it's just terrific and it just
makes it so easy for me I would forget
to eat my fruits and vegetables for six
months at a time field of greens makes
it really easy go to feel go to brick
house NOLs calm that's a dedicated URL
for it house Knowles calm also please
make that my nickname whenever you refer
to me I want to be referred to as brick
house Knowles makes me feel cool not so
much like a skinny boy get 15% off your
first order just for trying it out with
the promo code Knowles K no W
yes that is Brickhouse Knowles dot-com
promo code Knowles that's a lot of
Knowles and you're hearing that straight
from me good old Brickhouse Knowles
alright so the kids at Notre Dame
obviously have some issues going on and
they're producing this terrible art and
they're it's so incoherent it's
laughable that they choose to go to a
Catholic University named after our lady
and then they're shocked and appalled
and horrified because some of the
students there were Catholic I bet not
even most of the students are practicing
Catholics but just some of them are and
they espouse Catholic views and you're
not allowed to do that at a Catholic
school the two thoughts on this first of
all on the broader political point what
this shows us is a big aspect of this
debate between so Rob Amari and David
French and whatever you think about
those two guys and whatever even you
think about the debate the premise here
the premise that so Rob Amari is
attacking whether you think it's fair or
not the premise is that in the liberal
society we're not going to make any
grand moral statements okay we're not
gonna everything's just going to be
neutral and what the religious
conservatives and so Rober saying is
there's no such thing as neutrality like
that everybody's got to serve somebody
and so the liberal society is going to
enshrine certain virtues and moral
precepts and those will either be
conducive to the good or will be
detrimental to the good the other thing
is going after is that in this kind of
liberal idea we'll just carve out one
little section of society for religion
and look you can practice your religion
there and you're not gonna be able to
practice it everywhere but you practice
it there and that's gonna be okay and
what's so Rob was saying is that's not
true you're not when you have that
little cutout for religion they're just
gonna go after that next and if you look
at this story it's hard to disagree with
them we're not just talking about a
religious institution we're not just
talking about one university we're
talking about the Catholic University
and American Notre Dame the students are
trying to shut down Catholicism and
Notre Dame and by the way increasingly
they're being successful at school has
really gone downhill in recent years so
that's just the broader political point
it shows you gosh
we really are in the midst of a culture
war somebody's gonna win Cardinal
Manning said that bottom all political
disagreements or theological
disagreements and we are fighting in
many ways a religious war it's not a
religious war between Catholics and
Protestants or between Muslims and
Christians or anything like that it's a
religious war between the religious
those who have traditional religion and
this neo-pagan leftism it's a religious
war between those people who go to
church and those people who worship at
the altar of the Sun monster and climate
change it's it's the kooky materialist
religions of the left versus traditional
religion that's the broad political
point when it comes to the kids that
what to do about these shrieking crazy
wacky uneducated kids it reminds me of
John Stuart Mill's description of the
difference between a conservative and a
radical so the philosopher John Stuart
Mill says the radical the rationalist
the follower of Jeremy Bentham looks at
a received opinion and he asks is it
true
that's all he asks is it true the
conservative like thomas carlyle looks
at a received opinion and says what does
it mean and I think that's that's a
helpful way to look at the kids I mean
we should laugh and make fun of the
hysterics but we should also ask the
question what does it mean what does it
mean that these students who are very
privileged who are materially very
well-off even the ones who are well-off
are very well-off they're in expensive
schools in the richest country in the
history of the world what does it mean
that they are losing their minds I was
talking to a friend of mine last night
after the speech at GW and she's very
insightful on these kind of matters and
she said it's easy enough to say that
these kids are totally lunatics to be
upset but maybe they're right to be
upset they're just upset about the wrong
things and that really struck me it's
very much that conservative response
what does it mean these students really
are upset I've been to enough of these
campuses I've talked to enough of these
students to know they are genuinely
irate furious maddened and losing it and
a lot of them are unhappy
pills and a lot of them are have have
real problems what does it mean what are
the kids so upset about I think the
answer is before us and it's an answer
that conservatives really can get behind
we'll get to that in just one second but
first I've got to thank my friends over
at Daniels NYC you know how much I love
Daniels NYC Daniels NYC makes extremely
high quality beautifully designed
leather briefcases and this is a real
point for me I used to do this too and I
see all my millennial and Gen Z friends
do this even some people who are older
they walk around in a business suit or
in a nice oxford shirt and slacks or
they're going to their job or their
first job interview and they have a
backpack oh this sends chills up and
down my spine don't you're an adult okay
you are an adult if you want to be
treated like an adult you need to behave
like an adult part of that is ditching
the backpack because you're not in sixth
grade anymore you need a briefcase and
not just any briefcase because I know
briefcases are very expensive even if
you want some canvas bags sometimes it
can go through five six hundred dollars
Daniels figured it out Daniel's in New
York city-based
men's leather briefcase brand they make
exceptional quality and and most
importantly beautifully styled
beautifully designed briefcases mine is
the brown leather it's got nice you know
little zippers and things on it buttons
the buttons are really nice and then the
liner on the inside is this a little
pattern of foxes subtle but it's very
New York it's very it's got the kind of
New York slash Ivy League look to it but
it's subtle it's looks really great
because Daniels cuts out the middleman
they sell directly to you Daniel's is
able to offer a high quality luxury
leather briefcase at an unbelievable
price of one hundred and ninety five
dollars I've had really nice briefcases
throughout my life I just kind of got
them as hand-me-downs and things like
that even to get a not so nice briefcase
can cost you four or five hundred bucks
Daniel's gives you it is my favorite
briefcase I have one hundred ninety five
bucks you're not going to beat that
anywhere it is so cool right now this
week my listeners get twenty five
dollars off their Daniels briefcase at
Daniel's NYC dot-com so you got another
twenty five dollars off by using the
promo code Michael mi CH AE L at
checkout that's 25 by
off one of their leather briefcases
they're great I mean I can't I can't say
enough about them the sizing is great
they're not those big clunky things back
when laptops were basically desktops
they're really just made for 2019 with
that classic styling that always looks
good plus they offer free shipping
daniels NYC comm promo code michael mi
CH AE l 25 bucks off a handcrafted
high-quality leather briefcase with free
shipping ditch the backpack please don't
don't send shutters up and down my spine
ditch the backpack start looking like a
pro and and with Daniels you can
actually afford it before you land the
big job Daniel's NYC dot-com I love
their briefcases and I'm confident you
will too the question is what are these
kids upset about the ones at GW the ones
at Notre Dame the ones that you see on
viral videos at campuses all across the
country or the conservatives look at
them often we say you kids are rich kids
you spoiled little rich brats shut up
and stop complaining and stop whining
fair enough but something tells me
they're not upset about their material
prosperity okay materially we are all
doing great even people who are
struggling financially at various
periods still doing pretty great because
we live in an unbelievably rich country
now the answer shut up stop complaining
you've got iPads you've got iPhones
you've got lots of good money
that's a flippin answer because we say
that on the one hand and then on the
other hand conservatives know that the
world is not just material it's not even
primarily material Ronald Reagan
famously quoted Winston Churchill who
said when great forces are on the move
in the world we learned that we're
spirits not animals the destiny of man
is not measured by material computation
we are primarily religious beings we're
primarily spiritual beings we are not I
mean we have a body we're unified we're
not it's not like I'm not physical at
all but it's that old adage money can't
buy happiness money can buy a jet ski
and people are happy on jet skis but
you're not on a jet ski all the time all
right you're on a jet ski at most what
an hour a day if you're near the water
come on money actually can't buy
happiness and so to take right off what
these kids are saying and said well say
you're rich kids you're having a good
time that doesn't really get to
so they're not I don't think they're
upset about money or they upset about
politics yeah I guess they're upset that
their preferred politician lost in 2016
I mean there was a study that came out
of I think was ASU which showed that 25
percent of college students surveyed
reported ptsd-like effects months and
months after the presidential election
because their candidate lost him in
another candidate won I mean that's
crazy stuff but they really did show
clinically high levels of stress they
really are upset about their politics
what does that say it means maybe
they've been taught a version of
American politics that isn't true and
maybe our political institutions have
been degraded and maybe faith in our
systems of government has eroded that
tells us something what about the
culture maybe they're upset about the
culture they damn well should be upset
about the culture our culture is
terribly degraded in the mid twentieth
century huge numbers of Americans
perhaps the majority subscribed to
symphonies subscribed to local artistic
venues that number has plummeted that is
simply not the case anymore and even for
the people who weren't going to
symphonies virtually everybody was a
member of civic associations that the
same free associations that Alexes de
Tocqueville talked about in democracy in
America the the Lions Club the the
Kiwanis Club the bowling league people
were members of those and they would go
out and see their fellow Americans and
have friendships and go to each other's
houses that doesn't really happen
anymore those numbers have all plummeted
and people increasingly don't know their
fellow Americans and you see this also
because of urbanization the irony is
I've lived in cities most of my life
you know many more people when you live
in a small town than you do when you
live in a city I would live in cities in
New York with hundreds and hundreds of
people maybe more than that I knew like
five of them because you just don't meet
your neighbors when you're in a city you
just kind of keep your head down you
keep walking
that's the way it goes when you're in a
small town you know everybody everybody
knows everybody's business it's kind of
frustrating sometimes but there is a
community there it's not as isolating I
think young people increasingly have
every right
to be upset about their culture and
maybe their misplacing that anger onto
some politician or some conservative
speaker on campus or they're putting on
a George Washington or Christopher
Columbus but but the anxiety that
they're feeling is real and then most
importantly you got the politics you got
the culture maybe they're upset about
religion in fact I know they're upset
about religion because by and large and
increasingly they have been denied
religion it's not even that they've been
taught some religion that isn't true or
they were brought to the wrong Church
and they want to go to a different
Church they've been denied serious
religious education they've been denied
even the question they've been denied
the very fact that they are spiritual
beings that man is a religious being
increasingly children are being raised
without religion they're part of the
nuns not nu NS but n o n s they have no
religious affiliation and so they
channeled their natural religious
longings man has a god-shaped hole in
his heart that's true of everybody they
channel that into the wrong places so
they misplace that into politics or they
misplace that into their favorite online
personality or they channel that into
the weather and they worship the weather
and that is going to make people
miserable and that's not their fault
that they were deprived that education I
was sitting with a friend of mine a few
friends of mine in New York and we were
in this beautiful little private
residence and someone was playing a
Chopin Nocturne on the piano and this
was midnight and everybody had had a few
Coca Cola's or we'd had a few adult
beverages and we were just sitting there
maybe five or six of us listening
quietly to this beautiful performance of
a Chopin Nocturne slightly drunken
performance but still excellent and we
thought gosh this is so lovely and my
friend turned and pointed outside and he
said so many people out there don't even
know this exists and that's pretty sad
I'm not saying that you need to sit
quietly and listen to Chopin Nocturne
'he's all the time but it's really nice
to do that it's really nice to know that
those things exist it's it's the same
difference between you know you love
Hershey's chocolate
I still like Hershey's chocolate but I
like it less now than I
used to when I was a kid and the reason
I like it less now is because I have
discovered other things that I like on
my taste palate darker chocolate for
instance or Scotch or different kinds of
food or cigars or as you are educated
and I don't mean that book learnin I
mean as you grow and mature as a human
being your tastes change it's not just
the taste you put in your mouth it's the
tastes your intellectual tastes your
music tastes your artistic tastes all of
those things that has been denied for a
lot of people and so they're still stuck
with those basic things CS Lewis writes
about this how kids think you know when
they're little they say all they want is
chocolate and candy and they say this is
the greatest thing ever and it's because
they don't know about sex so you know
when they when they get a little bit
older and they learn about that they say
up now I was wrong about the chocolate
in the candy there is something better
than chocolate and candy but for this
whole generation because they've been
denied culture because they've been
denied education they're stuck in this
this suspended adolescence and they it
doesn't feel good you nobody wants to be
an overgrown child we see anxiety
depression stress our way up among these
kids among teenagers suicidality is up
70 percent in just the last two years
the kids are not alright and they're not
upset about George Washington and
Catholic sexual ethics they're upset
about something else fair enough they're
upset that our politics is shallower
that our culture is degraded and they
have no freaking clue what they were
made for and why that's a big problem
and the problem is not going to go away
the problem the problem doesn't just go
away there's a there's a viral video
that just came out of a Michigan
congressman Haley Stevens shrieking
shrieking at her constituents like those
leftists at GW like those kids at Notre
Dame she's not much older than them
she's a millennial too she's 36 years
old she would fit right in with the slam
poetry girls what is she shrieking about
she strike shrieking about her civil
right to own a firearm
she's shrieking about a civil rights
organization existing to protect those
rights here is congresswoman Haley
Stevens
got to go she's reading the NRA or our
right to lobby are our representatives
in the First Amendment that's got to go
our civil rights they've got to go she
just she doesn't understand what the NRA
is she doesn't understand what our
Constitution is in part it's her fault
because she's an overgrown child but in
part she was obviously denied a proper
education
you remember Maxine Waters Maxine Waters
not a millennial let's put it that way
she is now complaining because she can't
go out to the store people mob her
people yell at her she has to have
private security here she is on
television complaining oh absolutely I
mean I can't go to the grocery store
anymore by myself I have to pay for
security all the time oh that's too bad
I don't like that at all they have
security for me now when I go to
campuses because people attack me and I
think that's wrong and I think it's
wrong that they attack Maxine Waters I
wonder where they got the idea that they
could just go out and attack politicians
I wonder where these terrible people
might have heard that they could go out
and attack politicians like Maxine
Waters I wonder if they heard it from
checking my notes Maxine Waters
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's that's probably where they heard
it from I got to say so Maxine sorry you
know maybe you planted the seeds that's
an ugly society a society that says mob
your politicians and mob your historical
figures and get rid of George Washington
get rid of Columbus shriek at your
classmates hate everybody half the
country is deplorable and irredeemable
don't forgive anybody for anything don't
try to understand what they're saying
that's a terrible Society and there was
a moment there was a moment that did go
viral yesterday at the trial of former
Dallas Police Department officer amber
Geiger that shows you the alternative
amber Geiger shot this poor guy both
Amin in his own apartment she thought
that she was entering her apartment she
was on the wrong floor and she saw him
sitting on what she thought was her
couch she shoots him dead but it was his
couch in his apartment she was she's
found guilty of murder and the deceased
man's brother came out and made an
incredible statement we'll get to that
in a second we'll get to the mailbag -
but first I gotta say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube most importantly
speaking of culture and good culture
another Kingdom Season 3 is just days
away this is the final season that's a
trilogy and it is really fantastic I I
can say this because all I do is read
the words that Andrew Clavin wrote it is
so good I mean it is it is really
powerful and we talk all the time about
how conservatives need to get in the
culture and need to transform our
politics through our culture drew did
that with another Kingdom it is just so
powerful episodes 1 & 2 are going to be
released on Monday October 7th that's
you know for the hoi polloi the general
public but daily wire subscribers get
exclusive access to them tomorrow so if
that's not enough of a reason head on
over subscribe today subscribers also
exclusively can catch up on the past
seasons now at daily wire.com so get
ready for the final season coming out
head on over to daily wire.com you know
what it is 10 bucks and 100 dollars for
an annual membership you get all that
great stuff and you get to ask questions
in the mailbag which we're gonna come
back with right quickly so go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back
okay so you've got this awful shallow
Society vindictive society that hates it
one another and then you have this scene
from the trial of amber Geiger amber
Geiger former Dallas police officer
shoots both am gene dead in his own
apartment because she thinks that she
was in her apartment which I guess was a
couple floors away she's found guilty of
murder
not even manslaughter but murder and she
was sentenced yesterday to ten years in
prison and the deceased man's brought me
he was I think the guy was 26 years old
shot dead in his own apartment for doing
nothing wrong absolutely tragic story
heartbreaking story and even the fact
that she didn't mean to do it she just
got the apartment wrong I mean it just
it just makes you weep for Humanity and
weep for yourself and her the deceased
man's brother made a statement at this
sentencing and it was I won't do a
justice I won't even summon up it is one
of the most moving videos I have ever
seen one of the most moving statements
I've ever heard give a listen and I
wasn't gonna ever say this in front of
my family or anyone but I don't even
want you to go to jail I want the best
for you because I know that's what
that's exactly what both one would want
you to do and the best would be gave
your life to Christ just I'm not gonna
say anything else
I think giving your life to Christ and
be the best thing that both don't want
you to do again I love you
as a person
I had always anything bad are you I
don't know if this is possible but yeah
can I give her a hug please please yes
it's an unbelievable scene that's a man
with far greater understanding of the
world than the girls on the video or the
kids who shriek or the people who are
yelling and screaming and upset and
demanding revenge and and being
vindictive to their countrymen and
calling half of them deplorable and
irredeemable this woman shot his brother
dead at in his mid-20s in his own
apartment and he says I don't want
anything bad for you I want the best for
you I love you you should give your life
to Christ he's not just doing it because
of some shallow political ideology he's
doing it because his savior lives and
he's been commanded to do that by the
man who made him that is a beautiful
society imagine living in that society
this isn't even the same as protesting
justice they're participating in justice
they're there at the justice system they
respect the decision of the courts there
is justice too and there is mercy
Shakespeare writes the quality of mercy
is not strain'd it droppeth as the
gentle rain from heaven upon the place
beneath it is twice blessed to blesseth
him that gives and him that takes
tis mightiest in the mightiest it
becomes the throned monarch better than
his crown his sceptre shows the force of
temporal power the attribute to awe and
Majesty wherein doth sit the dread and
fear of Kings mercy is an attribute to
God himself and that we're only going to
get that society back if we behave that
way too we need to have a sense of that
too it's why when people scream and
shout at me whether it's on television
or on on camera or anything like that at
one of these campuses I do my best I
don't always succeed but I do my best
not to give it right back to them not to
get angry and take it personally not
because what good is that going to do
what good is that possibly going to
these people are very confused in this
culture and there's a lot of pain and
there's original sin and there's a
fallen world and we can have if we can
show a little bit of mercy it can be
unbelievably powerful and and we're very
likely not going to achieve even one one
zillion of the grace that you see there
with that with that man talking about
his dead brother and the woman who
killed him but if you show people that
society and you show people to Screech's
shouty I hate you I hate you because
George Washington was a fascist or
something there's no question that we we
want to live in the former the Society
of mercy and grace and for the
uneducated ignorant uncultured
anxiety-ridden stressed-out young people
I think the big problem is they don't
even know that that society can exist
all right we've got to get to the
mailbag in our last moments I always run
late first question from Nathan will we
see an impact on the youngest generation
as adults due to today's twist to gender
norms safe spaces etc well of course
it's funny funny question to ask on this
show I think the show basically answers
that question itself not only will we
see the impact but we're seeing the
impact now we're seeing it in the rates
of anxiety stress suicidality in the the
prescription of psychiatric medications
and depression pills even to teenage
years even to 12 year olds but we're
seeing the effects now of this kind of
confusion and it's not merely a
scientific confusion though there's a
lot of that it's not merely a political
or a cultural one it is a metaphysical
spiritual and religious confusion as
well and what's so ironic about it is so
much of the argument from the Atheist
left is we need to ditch religion we
need to keep religion out of public life
we need to stop talking about the world
as though God made it because only then
can we get to scientific reality what
world has that given us what we now no
longer admit that men are different than
women we now castrate young children and
block them from going through puberty
because their parents think in some
metaphysical way their little boys are
actually little girls the moment we
severed religious rial
from public life we didn't get more
science we completely destroyed science
and we got pseudo-scientific cultist
movements like the cult of catastrophic
climate change that's gonna kill us all
in 10 years you don't you don't lose
some religion and get more science you
lose religion and you lose science too
because of course science is predicated
on certain religious premises and on
faith we're seeing the impact today and
young people are a crystal ball the
campuses are a crystal ball they show
you your future in twenty years we're
seeing that and that congresswoman is 36
years old now you got to fix the problem
problem not all problems go away with
time and if we're not going to fix that
problem it's only gonna get worse from
Connor I find it more difficult to keep
up with local politics in comparison to
that on a national level can you provide
advice on some of the factors or
qualities you look for when choosing who
to vote for in local elections
especially when candidates make campaign
on platforms you are less familiar with
or which seem to be indistinguishable
from the field yes politics is
increasingly national it used to be
primarily local so Tip O'Neill the
Democratic Speaker of the House used to
say all politics is local that might
have been true even as late as the 80s
or 90s but it is not true today
now all elections are referenda on
national politics that referenda on
Trump or something
so when you're voting and you know
especially in LA you get all these
different candidates and they hide their
political views and you can't even see
the political affiliation this is one of
the reasons political parties exist is
because they show you what the
differences are you get a choice not an
echo so there's no way you're gonna have
time to research every single candidate
for every single office that's why if
you tend to be more conservative usually
it makes sense to vote for the
Republican if you tend to be more
leftist usually it makes sense to vote
for the Democrat this isn't always true
sometimes candidates their Republican
candidates who are really just terrible
people and there are Democratic
candidates who are actually more
conservative and more reliable so
occasionally it makes sense
to vote for the other person you'll know
who those people are if they run a good
cam
and if they run the good campaign then
maybe that's evidence that you should
vote for them you'll know who those
people are if you meet one of those
república this has happened to me I
voted against Republicans before because
I met him and I knew they were just it's
sociopaths who didn't believe in
anything so I'm not going to vote for
that person even though they say that
they believe what I believe in I can't
trust that they'll even do the people's
work the party I know it's very
fashionable these days to say parties
are a terrible thing we got to get rid
of political parties political parties
exist for a reason they make politics a
little clearer that's one good way to do
it and the other good way to do it is to
judge people on their campaigns
campaigns have consequences and nobody
would have put their money on Donald
Trump in 2014-2015 and yet he ran the
best campaign and he's been a and by the
way we didn't even know his religious
affiliation because he'd worked with
Democrats so much of his life but he ran
the best campaign he was trustworthy and
he got elected that's that that would be
a good guide on the national level even
at local politics from Lena I'm a hard
worker and I've been putting in 10 to 12
hour days for the past 10 months at my
job now I'm starting to feel burnt out
and I find it a bit depressing to think
that this is just what the future looks
like I'm torn between making a steady
paycheck or taking a leap and seeing
what else is out there what would you do
in this situation you asked the wrong
person Lena if you want the advice to
stay in your steady job because but I
bet you're asking the question because
you know that's not the advice I'm going
to give you I have done my best in my
life to avoid stable and steady
employment the two industries that I've
worked in usually simultaneously or
politics and show business the most
volatile industries that very often have
nothing to do with even talent or skill
or hard work and are largely based on
chance although I do think actually work
pays off in the end of that and I don't
regret a thing I loved it I have gone
through huge periods of unemployment I
have had massive ups and massive downs
in those industries and I wouldn't
change it for the world
now the funny thing about this is I work
ten to twelve hour days I work more than
that most days doesn't feel like it
though it doesn't feel like it if you're
doing what you really want to be doing
and you
feel like you're having some impact in
the work that you're doing matters so
you know what I would do
I would take a leap and do what you want
to do this doesn't mean be stupid about
it I think some people hear this and
they say okay great I'm gonna move to
Hollywood and not have any other job and
not have any income and I'm just gonna
be a big movie star or I'm gonna go into
politics and I'm gonna become a big
senator instantly and I'm not gonna no
that's not how reality works you gotta
if you want to do something that you
really really want to do that's in a
high risk field
you got to work even harder if 12-hour
days are too much you're gonna have to
work a lot more than that stable steady
employment is a good thing if you find
it's not fulfilling in life you can find
fulfillment elsewhere you can find
fulfillment in family you can find
fulfillment in your civic associations
and of course you can find fulfilment in
your religious life in your spiritual
life doesn't mean that everybody needs
to go out there and become a movie star
or run for president but what it what it
does mean is everything is going to have
those costs and what it also means is
this is your life this is it
you didn't choose one to be born into
this world most likely you're not gonna
have any say in how you go out and
you're gonna get to the end of your life
and you may have regrets so you don't
want to have those regrets you want to
do the right thing and and not feel that
you squandered the precious life that
was given to you which is a gift and
when when you've really got nothing to
lose all you've got to do is do the
right thing and work hard so I am NOT
going to tell you which one to do keep
the stable job or go out and do some
crazy thing I don't even know what what
it would be that you want to do but you
do have life is all about those choices
and you do have nothing to lose and I
always say go for it it's worked out but
I know a lot of people who burned out
along the way from Tanner oh mighty
cigar wizard just want to say I'm a big
fan of your show non politics related
question is there any modern music or
genre that you genuinely enjoy what is
your favorite style and we're band yes
yes there is I love soul music I love
funk music I I do like some modern rock
bands I love I liked Queen Queen is a
great band
I like wings I'm the only heterosexual
man in America that likes Paul
McCartney's band wings I in terms of
like really I mean when I can say modern
I'm talking about post-world War one
I obviously love the American Songbook
guys in terms of really like actual new
stuff ah I know who and this this might
be a note to leave on I really like
Nickelback these days I didn't used to
like Nickelback I used to think
Nickelback was the worst band that was
ever graced any stage in America but
then President Trump sent out that tweet
that look at this photograph tweet he
took Nickelback and used it as a just
Kajol against Joe Biden the Democrats it
really gave me a strange new respect for
Nickelback alright that's our show in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles oh have a good
weekend see you Monday
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director
Pavel why douse key edited by Danny
D'Amico audio is mixed by Mike core
Amina hair and makeup is by Jessa
all Vera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show it seems
President Trump is getting sick and
tired of being lied about 24 hours a day
seven days a week the press can't
understand it what's the big deal they
say isn't that what we always do two
Republican presidents hilarity ensues on
the Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin
[Music]